on a un nid qui a 15 m il est gros comme
une machine à laver allez bonjour à tous
Aujourd'hui on a une nouveauté vous le
reconnaissez oui alors instant tu
pourrais dire bonjour voilà vous le
connaissez bon allez aujourd'hui
j'accueille à Mont-de-Marsan Baptiste
salut salut Quentin
les pêcheurs de trésor alors et ben moi
je ce que je veux voir c'est la suite
quoi
alors regarde
je l'ai perdu non
une double chance je vais vous montrer
pourquoi parce que bon déjà ils ont un
aimant ça c'est bien regardez vous êtes
prêts allez on est prêt
[Musique]
effectivement bon écoute que te dire
c'est comment bien
donc bon à mon avis ça va être une
grande journée quoi ça commence bien ça
commence bien à tout de suite voilà la
découverte et bien sûr on est en
compagnie de Étienne
qui nous a invité à venir pêcher à
l'aimant dans son coin et ma foi ça
commence bien calibre 4.5 donc c'est
bien ça c'est du plomb c'est du plomb
Manu arme mais tu vois je pense qu'elle
est restaurable
hâte de tirer dans le garage avec ça
un pédalier de vélo
on va descendre sur le bord je pense
découverte des tiennes sur la rive alors
moi j'ai pas besoin de l'aimant j'ai
juste eu besoin de mes yeux ça me saoule
à faire à suivre
mais il y a des trucs justement c'est
tellement peu accessible que la personne
vient pêcher je pense
non regardez un poste ah non c'est
peut-être pas un poste
parce qu'il y a un truc warning security
c'est bizarre
scanner mais c'est dangereux alors
d'accord ah c'est original je te
l'envoie
non
ça brille
[Applaudissements]
il est beau hein
c'est quoi c'est l'inox non ouais je
pense
c'est sympa
de cheminée
j'en ai déjà attaqué quand j'étais gosse
ouais j'avais une seule piqûre ça va
mis plein de plein d'habits les uns sur
les autres et il était allé les le taper
avec une barre
de piscine
il était fier de sa bêtise
ça c'était un gros nid qui avait dans
une cabane de jardin européen ou à dire
non je crois
en vrai c'est impressionnant il avait
tapé il a eu son coup il avait couru
après
mon petit rasta ça va mon bébé
c'est possible comme le portable on va
aller voir celle-là si elle est pleine
non il y avait une poche avant l'autre
alors
dommage nous laisse jamais rien
bon j'ai péché l'apéro
bon et bien Étienne vient d'être appelé
pour une alerte frelante donc on va le
rejoindre il a des combinaisons pour
nous je crois qu'il y en a pas pour
rasta mais bon il attendra dans la
voiture c'est pas grave on le mettra à
l'ombre et hâte que tu en penses ouais
faut ranger d'abord ou pas des frelons
non quand j'étais petit j'attaquais en
main nu alors on va voir si ça se passe
aussi bien cette fois-ci c'est ma vie ça
à moi
ah ouais la belle bête alors faut faire
attention parce que ça c'est un insecte
très très rapide et qui peut piquer une
dizaine de fois chacun donc en fait ça
c'est alors c'est typique en fait la
personne ne voit pas parce que regarde
tous les aller-retours qu'il y a là
regarde pas en l'air et en fait déjà
elle regarde pas en l'air et à mon avis
elle rentre en voiture ici elle fait le
tour et elle repart par là d'accord
donc on va traiter ça rapide
on va traiter ça rapide le seul signe
qu'il y a tu vois c'est les déjections
qui est un peu par terre c'est tout
c'est quel type de Frelon du coup là
asiatique
l'œuf plomb qui nous mange tous
l'écosystème le fameux le fameux deux
paires d'elle décollé et que du coup qui
fait un super rafale
alors ce que je vous propose c'est très
simple on va le faire un peu à l'aide du
Lot vous vous allez vous mettre ici vous
allez regarder et moi je vais le faire
j'en ai pour deux minutes faut pas se
louper
on attend de voir ça il faut un aimant
c'est ça alors ça c'est très utile c'est
idéal pour l'année 2022 où on n'a pas eu
beaucoup de frelons donc on peut faire
plein de choses le fait que j'ai
accueilli dans les Landes nos amis chez
ça chasseur de trésor j'en profite
d'ailleurs pour remercier nos
partenaires maison de la détection qui
nous ont permis d'organiser cette
rencontre avec Etienne vous pouvez
trouver sur leur site tout le matériel
nécessaire pour faire de la pêche à
l'aimant ainsi que de la détection il y
avait des kits qui sont super adaptés à
différents niveaux de pêche à l'aimant
et surtout à différents budgets le lien
vers petite est affiché en description
de la vidéo donc en fait c'est beaucoup
plus organisé que ça dans ma voiture
thermiquement non c'est pas vrai ça
là du coup tu mets je mets une petite
dose insecticide
dans le nid on laisse le nid tranquille
et
on se trompe pas de bonnes
d'accord donc tu fais pas tomber le
nids le but du jeu là en plus sur un
lieu de vie donc en fait il faut
il faut percer un petit peu sur le côté
pour éviter qu'en fait les frelons quand
ils vont naître ils vont tomber alors
ils touchent la scepticide ils sont
morts mais mine de rien ils vont quand
même tomber donc voilà d'accord et ça
c'est ici que n'importe qui peut acheter
ou c'est non voilà c'est surpuissant
donc un petit compresseur ça monte assez
rare c'est aussi barre ça fait six fois
le volume donc
si vous voulez essayer je vous laisserai
une tempête on a eu la dose avec le
travail tout à l'heure
et on a plus noté que sur le treuil il y
en a qu'un qui s'en est servi on dit
rien je peux pas la merde oh c'est
normal moi je me baigne à chaque fois
ça reste un insecticide mais c'est pas
super polluant on va dire ça c'est quand
même
de plus en plus propre et ça c'est bien
sûr
après faut pas rester en plein vous
mettez là sur le côté
c'est moi qui te ferme OK et c'est moi
qui t'ouvre surtout OK
donc là il y a une belle perche tu vas
arriver tu vas penser à ouvrir le
robinet au dernier moment ok et tu vas
poser ça sur le
sur le nid et au moment où tu vas poser
donc tu ouvres un peu avant au moment où
tu poses pitch un petit coup un tout
petit d'accord mais bien dans le nid et
tu restes là pour regarder comment ça se
passe OK regarde pas toi quand même
[Musique]
c'est magique et oui non pas les frelons
toi tu es trop petit
nouvelle mission ah ouais il est énorme
en plus et c'est pas moi qui l'ai vu
c'est les voisins
en fait c'est normal ben là tu sais ce
que tu vas faire on va te mettre la
GoPro sur la perche ah ouais c'est bien
ça après si tu veux
faire passer après
mais bon maintenant je pourrais voir
l'autre après si tu veux c'est une
échelle tu peux y monter là
tu montes sans problème
ça se fait mais après ça sert à rien
il est vivant
je vais [ __ ] je vais le descendre le
pain ah bah voilà comme ça alors déjà si
en plus vous aimez pas votre temps je
pense que le mieux en effet c'est
ça
alors là en fait tu as tu as deux
solutions pour le faire c'est tu as le
pulpe c'est à dire le fusil insecticide
c'est marrant mais ça coûte une blinde
et voilà ou après tu as la perche
d'accord ok et là la perche en
l'occurrence c'est scanne mieux
je peux monter jusqu'à 30 mètres
il est gros comme une machine à laver tu
as un être hyper agressif à tes pieds tu
connais c'est un chien donc là on va
faire en sorte de monter cet engin là
haut parce que autrement on en avait un
courageux là qui voulait monter etc il
était prêt à monter mais bon quand je
lui ai expliqué qu'en fin de compte on
pouvait le faire avec la perche il a dit
ok on signe donc ce qu'on fait on vous
met la GoPro là-haut et vous allez tout
voir c'est nickel
c'est pas que
voilà on approche du nid
lever le pied comme ça ouais allez-y là
vous lever le pied et
[Musique]
elle est dangereuse
et ça pue aussi c'est ça
c'est le venin c'est en fait c'est un
mélange de d'urine et de venin ok donc
en fait il faut bien vous dire que là le
frelon il vous a pissé dessus
nous on a touché
tu l'as dit après tu vois
en fait il y a des phéromones sur la
GoPro
on va la rincer un peu on est pêcher
avec
bon ben là on a quelque chose de très
gros donc on a direct sorti le treuil de
tonne
et on va
à l'origine j'ai dit on tire avec le 4x4
le suppo il tire tout lui mais bon ils
m'ont dit bof
si le poids il passe par dessus c'est
pas bon quoi
qu'est-ce qui finit 4 4 qui finit dans
l'eau on remonte l'objet
qu'est-ce que vous préférez voir en
vidéo parce que le 4x4 en vidéo qui
finit à la base ça fait le buzz
du buzz pardon c'est du bug
une petite rondelle
j'ai une cuisinière à bois d'accord donc
ça peut expliquer le poids
ça y est travaille à l'eau
attends mais c'est quoi ça c'est pas
notre corps regardez il y a un grappin
et un aimant
é
aussi
ok
de réussir à finir cette histoire si
vous retrouvez votre grappin et votre
aimant
ce que je vais les offrir à Étienne
parce que il débute il a besoin de
matériel solides merci
on tente bon on tire on va tirer
[Musique]
comment vous dire Vincent rigole plus
franchement si vous savez en commentaire
ce que c'est mais je pense que c'était
sur le gros objet on va retirer dessus
on va voir ouh là haut ça vient encore
ça avait l'air gros
[Musique]
c'est un truc pour faire des trous dans
le bois d'accord ah oui après tu mets
peut-être quelque chose
une pelle
elle est parfaite voilà une belle
fonctionnelle mais en vrai c'est au
moins la cinquième qu'on trouve ouais
c'est un classique
je sais pas pourquoi ils font tomber
leur pelle mais bon bah c'est cool je
prends
en vrai pour le road trip je pense qu'on
va te l'offrir
les deux
oui je crois que c'est bon je crois que
c'est bon
il a réussi son créneau et nous on a
réussi à sortir les morts
nous a emmené chassé du frelon asiatique
et nous on l'a emmené pêcher un pistolet
à plomb si cette vidéo vous a plu
dites-le en commentaire et on vous sera
un deuxième épisode dans lequel on va
chasser du frelon européen et tenté de
pêcher quelque chose encore mieux